Vous n'entendez que le son de ma voix
nous sommes dimanche
le jour des explications
Salut ! alors non je ne vais pas ouvrir une secte aujourd'hui
mais plutôt comme chaque dimanche vous expliquez quelque chose qui va vous permettre de bluffer les autres.
On a souvent parlé dans les vidéos des micros mouvements musculaires
même si j'ai pas encore fait de master class' là dessus, d'ailleurs ça viendra
plutôt à partir du mois de septembre
ou avant. peut être en Juillet, suivant le nombre de pouces en l'air sur cette vidéo
*rire*
C'est tellement du chantage ça !
On va utiliser la force de la suggestion
et les micros mouvements musculaires d'une personne
pour lui donner la sensation qu'un pendule peut recevoir ses pensées
votre seul rôle va être de suggérer que c'est possible
alors je ne vais pas vous donner un tour particulier parce que c'est applicable à pleins de choses
vous pourriez demander à quelqu'un de choisir une carte
vous pourriez l'adapter à énormément de choses
on va parler d'une méthode que vous pouvez faire nimporte où
vous demandez à une personne de sortir 4 objets et de les mettre devant elle
ensuite vous lui demandez d'écrire sur un bout de papier l'objet qu'elle a choisi dans sa tête
si vous n'avez pas de papier elle peut l’écrire dans son téléphone par exemple
le seul but c'est de pouvoir ré-accéder à cette information plus tard à la fin
et vous lui confiez un pendule
Alors ça c'est un "vrai" pendule
Un vrai pendule à pas cher
mais ça marcherait aussi bien en prenant une bague et en l'attachant au bout d'une chaîne
ou même en attachant une gomme au bout d'un lacet
Le but du jeu c'est d'avoir quelque chose de lourd au bout d'un fil
Vous demandez ensuite à la personne de tenir le pendule de la manière suivante
Un petit peu de la chaîne à l'intérieur de la main
ça repasse sur l'index, et ça retombe de l'autre côté
on referme les doigts comme ceci et on place le pouce dessus au niveau de l'index
Vous pouvez également lui faire tenir comme ceci, mais alors vraiment du bout, du bout, du bout de la chaîne
Dans ce cas là, la prise doit être ferme
Et vous allez lui suggérer par votre discours
Il n'y a pas de discours écrit parce qu'il n'y a pas de bon ou de mauvais discours
Le seul but, c'est d'avoir une attention de suggestion
Pour lui faire penser réellement que le pendule va bouger au dessus de l'objet qu'elle a choisi elle-même
Vous lui demandez de passer le pendule sur chaque objet
Un vrai temps, de prendre vraiment son temps. Quelques secondes au dessus de chaque objet
ça peut être 10 secondes à chaque fois, par exemple, un vrai moment
et quand le pendule est au dessus d'un objet, vous lui rappelez
que si c'est l'objet qu'elle a choisi, alors le pendule va se mettre à bouger
et à chaque objet, vous allez lui rappeler que
si c'est l'objet qu'elle a choisi mentalement
et qu'elle a écrit dans son portable ou sur un bout de papier
alors le pendule va se mettre à bouger.
Il va se mettre à bouger de plus en plus rapidement,
de plus en plus vite, de plus en plus rapidement
et si le pendule se met à bouger
et que vous lui faites passer un autre objet
Alors le pendule va s'arrêter.
Il va s'arrêter car il sait que ce n'est pas votre objet
c'est votre suggestion qui va provoquer de micro-mouvements
C'est une suggestion très puissante et très bluffante à utiliser
Encore une fois il n'y a pas de script précis
qu'on ait bien cette attention là
vous devez juste répéter
que si c'est l'objet choisi alors le pendule va bouger
et si c'est pas l'objet choisi alors le pendule va rester fixe
dans la grande, grande, très grande majorité des cas
ça fonctionnera très bien, car la personne a envie que ça marche
elle a envie de voir ça
et dès que ça va commencer à osciller
elle va se convaincre que c'est par rapport à ce que vous avez dit que ça bouge
et le fait qu'elle se dise ça
Alors son cerveau va envoyer encore une fois des micro-mouvements
qui vont accentuer encore le mouvement du pendule
et c'est un circuit comme ça vertueux
J'espère que ce tour un peu spéciale vous aura plu
et surtout que vous allez l'essayer
n'hésitez pas, prenez confiance en vous
faites-le, amusez vous avec
Vous pouvez très bien l'adapter à un jeu de cartes
moi je le fais comme ça
j'ai même envie de dire, ça va vous bluffer vous-même
j'espère donc que ça vous à plu, et que vous le ferez
si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en laissant un petit
pouce en l'air
et en me disant dans les commentaires comme ça c'est passé
je serai très curieux de lire ça !
Exceptionnellement demain, bien qu'on soit lundi ce ne sera pas un vlog
On parlera d'un truc geek
mais terrible
en attendant passez un excellent dimanche
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
Rendez-vous demain à 17h !
Ciao